you know to be great i think you have to
fight
and i very much think that my success is
a product of
some level of skill but i do think i win
because i outwork people i really do
believe that 100
and i'm not sure that if my dad didn't
set that example that i'd even have the
ability to think one could work that
hard
the fact that i've been working 19 hours
a day every day for the last 20 years is
easy for me it's the only gear i knew
right i was poor i sucked at school it
was the only gear i had you know i think
you need to recognize that um your
biggest advantage is that you're
hungrier than your competitor and that
if you are not applying
your one advantage which is your work
ethic and the hours that you have to put
into your business well then you're
going to come up short hey it's kevin
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that's holding you back a lack
of belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some powerful motivation
for success
enjoy
i sit here
with enormous assumptions around all of
you that you're just too soft to beat me
right that i think that you've had it
better and that that alone doesn't allow
you to beat me somebody will come with a
counter cultural point of view and be
like gary that's cool but i don't have
to work that hard because i'm working
smarter yeah me too [ __ ] i work hard
and smart now what
look there's a 12 hour 10 hour 8 hour 15
hour work day
you can finish a lot of things in those
18 12 9 hours or you can finish medium
amounts of things or lightweight things
people focus on too many small details
way too many people in this room are
going to spend the next 30 40 years of
their lives trying to check the boxes of
the things that they're not as good at
and that you're going to waste a load of
time and news
i highly recommend for all you hustlers
because there's a lot of you there's a
lot of you that are always talking about
gary i do work hard and you do you work
for 16 hours some people just don't have
the attention span or the capacity to
remember or like there's a lot of things
i can't learn i was very poor student
because the subject matter bored me and
if i was forced
to become great at understanding the
great artists of the 20th century i'm in
big trouble and so
i would tell people to bet on their
strengths you need to bet on your
strengths and don't give a [ __ ] about
what you suck at and to put themselves
in a position to win with their
strengths
because that is absolutely the
straightest line to success
greatness comes from adversity and and
looking the the challenge in the eye and
having the intestinal fortitude to kind
of uh
to
to step up and go after it rule number
two have a growth mindset with tom
billiard hey tom hello
so uh i have a company that's doing
eight figures in revenue
and it's been sitting in that range and
i've tried a few different things
when with your first company what did
you have to do to get it to nine figures
and what did you have to sacrifice
whether personal or in business so in
the first company to get to nine figures
we had to sell it and move into a
totally different company so this is
where are you in the right industry are
you solving the right problem and you
really have to look at that because the
reality is some businesses are just
eight-figure businesses
and so is this an eight-figure business
and what we need to be doing is pivoting
and finding something that opens us up
to a much larger vista or are we doing
something wrong so we run the physics of
progress we start with our goal our goal
is hyper specific then and this is the
art we have what is that problem are
there people in your industry that are
doing it are there nine figure
businesses in your industry if there are
nine figures in fact this is a really
useful life tool
who
is doing it well
okay you're trying to do something who's
doing it well
who's ahead of you right so i decide
that i'm going to try to make sure that
nobody gets to the age of 15 without
encountering a growth mindset that's my
mission in life okay everything i do is
about that
thank you
so now you work backwards my first
attempt was to just look into a camera
and say things like this act like this
and i realize two percent of people will
respond to it but 98 don't you will
never hear me say as long as i help one
person i'm not that guy i want to help
everybody
and at scale as much as humanly possible
so i started thinking about the 98
and i realized okay i'm gonna be
doing something in media either uh music
which sways culture video games uh
movies tv whatever that's gonna be and
so i decided given my passions and my
skill set that i'm going to be on the
film tv video game side
so who's done it well
who has
told only one kind of story right
because that's i can only make one kind
of story if i'm trying to give you a
growth mindset
i every story has to tell a growth
mindset so i was like has anybody ever
told one kind of story and built a
really successful
media company and the answer is
god damn right
disney told one kind of story over and
over and over from a thousand different
angles and in doing so he has swayed
culture to give you an idea my sister
went to disneyland 72 times in 12 months
pre-covert obviously
and i thought whoa like this place
really means something to her so if
disney can build the most magical place
on earth can i build the most empowering
place on earth now i don't just go copy
disney but i see a lot of the cues that
i need about what they did how they
swayed the psychology of the world and
so you want to find somebody that's
doing it and that's going to give you
those first clues you have to take
ownership of everything say everything
is my fault
and get real good at identifying that
problem whether it's we don't have
enough capital we don't have the right
product
i'm not the right sales person whatever
but you have to figure out what that
problem is do you have a guess what
holds you back
well uh there's well there is a
nine and ten figure businesses in my
industry and what they do is once a
company gets to eight figures they look
at buying them so that's the end goal so
what's the problem uh
trying to figure it out trying to figure
out that's
vague trying to figure out how to
i have to multiply the revenue by five
times to get to eight figures are you
saying though that you don't understand
which companies to buy
no uh
in my company when it gets to eight
figures nine and ten figure companies in
my industry buy them which is the goal
okay but so are you a seven figure
trying to be an eight or an eight trying
to be a nine no eight trying to be a
nine okay so if we know that people go
from eight to nine remember you said
this if we know that eights go to nines
by acquiring other companies the goal
is already obvious we have to go buy
companies at least that's one path true
or false
uh true but sorry what i meant
what i meant is when you go from eight
figures to nine figures
the nine figure ten figure companies buy
buy you at that point uh and you're
afraid you'll get purchased no i wanna
sell i wanna get to
tell me the problem in a single sentence
um
because just just to be clear when you
started unless i misunderstood you said
tom i'm an eight and i want to become a
nine how do i do it
and the answer is sitting right in front
of us but now when i say that's the
answer you say no no that's not the
problem
well what i was asking is what you
specifically did in your first company
to get from eight to nine we exited that
company and started a new one from
scratch because that was a market that
was never going to take us to nine
figures so so that's an option to look
at that then absolutely yeah
everything's on the table we're thinking
from first principles i didn't look at
that option so but it also sounds i'm a
little confused we'll move on but i'm a
little confused because you gave us the
answer which is to acquire other
companies so there's and now i'm going
to speak to everybody else about your
problem forgive me but like do you guys
see how
the answer he was able to articulate the
answer but there's something that
doesn't satisfy him in that answer
oh this is so important so if we've been
on sort of the 101 101 we're now in the
master's degree
this is where i see entrepreneurs get
tripped up all the time
there is a gap between what you feel
and what you can articulate
if you're living in a feeling
and you cannot say the problem in a
single sentence
your emotions
are making something feel obvious that
actually isn't obvious oh god this is so
important you're having a biological
experience this is one of those where i
would need a full week to walk you
through why it is so important to
understand i'm going to give it to you
real fast i've got still a little over
50 minutes okay this is really important
you're going to think i'm not talking
about business but i swear to god
i am
the conscious mind uses language
the subconscious mind
uses emotion
the conscious mind can process very
little data
the subconscious mind can process what
they call
faster
and vaster
so your subconscious mind can take in
all this information from the world
and it can't speak to you in language
so it's processing a lot of data a lot
of data all the data that's necessary
but
it can't communicate to you in words for
two reasons one we pass through infancy
and from an evolutionary perspective we
pass through millions of years of not
having sophisticated language but even
now
we
go through an extended period where we
cannot speak
but we have to have a way to communicate
so anybody that has kids know the way
the kids communicate is they have all
this data coming from their body they
get stressed and they just scream and so
it's this really simple feedback loop
and what i'm trying to get people to
understand
is that you're existing in that same
feedback loop right now in your business
so subconscious will speak to an emotion
you must learn to translate that emotion
into words a very simple conscious
thought that you can say in a single
sentence with no commas no run-ons no
parentheticals so there's nowhere to
hide
now
you're having a biological experience i
started by saying your brain is fine
with you you ready for a true story
who's ready for a true story
okay if this doesn't freak you out and
the story i'm about to tell you is going
to
explain 80 of the problems that you have
as a business owner this is so true and
you're not going to believe me
but i'm only ever going to say what is
true
this is a real study
you can read about it in very famous
textbooks
there is a region of the brain that you
can damage that will eliminate your
ability to form long-term memories
so you can form short-term memories but
if we meet and your this area of your
brain is damaged and i leave the room
and come back three minutes later you
won't remember me it's real okay it's
not just the movie momento it's a real
condition
so they would test this guy
and one time they had a doctor walk in
with a pin
in his hand
so when he reached out to shake the
guy's hand it poked him and the guy
pulled his hand back and was like whoa
doctor leaves the room waits three
minutes comes back in remember this
guy's not faking it
he does not know who this doctor is the
region of his brain that forms long-term
memories has been destroyed and so he
meets this doctor new
the doctor sticks out his hand
if he doesn't know who he is
he should reach out and just get pricked
over and over and over right
would you not assume that to be true
but he'll refuse to reach out they've
tested this on multiple people
now
and this is the important part
open your minds for me i want you to
hear what actually happens because this
is what's happening to you right now and
you don't realize it
when asked
why won't you shake this doctor's hand
what the guy said was
i've always had a long-standing problem
of shaking the hand of someone in a
white lab coat
that's a lie
has nothing to do with that it has to do
with a region of his brain stored a tie
between this guy
and pain
that can't articulate into the conscious
mind because of the memory storage
problem
but
the brain
will not
allow there to be no answer
the brain
will not
allow there to be no answer
so
when we run into a problem hey i'm an
eight figure business i'm trying to
become a nine-figure business you feel
like you know why
well it's because of this that or the
other
it's almost certainly true
that that narrative is the version of
your brain connecting some pain
you feel an emotion something doesn't
feel right you put it into words and
feel like cool i've got the words i can
use when somebody asks me about this
eighty percent maybe ninety
percent of the problems you face in your
business you have an emotional
understanding of
but you never take the time to question
the narrative that you've layered on top
of that and until you can pierce that
narrative and figure out what's really
going on using the physics of progress
you're never going to figure it out
so know
that you lie to yourself all the time
and it's the only way to get through
life we all do it you have to do it it's
actually a great strategy but to grow
your business you have to figure out how
to get through that and get to the other
side
because there's some emotion stopping
you rule number three embrace the
suffering with ed meidlet i want you to
write this down i need to embrace the
suffering you know there's something
powerful that once you just sort of
embrace the fact that in order to
achieve something big you've got to get
rid of these distractions and then the
other layer of it is you're probably
going to have to have some suffering to
get there or some sacrifice to get there
and so once you've embraced and decided
that this suffering this sacrifice
you're making is an indicator of
progress it's an indicator of obsession
suffering and sacrifice and hard work
is an indication of progress towards our
dreams the lack of sacrifice the lack of
suffering in our lives its removal its
non-existence
also equates to a non-existence of a
great life a non-existence of a dream
happening a big one anyway and so
embrace the fact that you're gonna have
to sacrifice and suffer to some extent
once you've embraced that it's going to
happen it's almost not that bad it's
kind of like those of you that are fit
we already know and you already know
even if you're not you've sort of
accepted that before you go to the gym
and get there you're gonna have to
suffer and we go anyway it becomes a
habit no one goes into a gym
thinking i'm not gonna have to sacrifice
or suffer there'll be no discomfort or
no pain but millions of people go anyway
don't they to the gym on some level
they're suffering in the gym whether
it's breathing heavy or sweating or
aches or pains or stress you know
everything in the gym is a sacrifice and
to some extent you're suffering going
through some pain
you know it before you go don't you
yet most of us go all the time
yet in life outside of that one area
most of us
are worried about suffering we're afraid
of it when we're suffering and
sacrificing we wonder whether it's worth
it we wonder whether we're supposed to
we wonder whether sacrifice or setbacks
or suffering is a sign it's not our real
dream don't we see at the gym you never
think oh i'm going through some pain and
discomfort this must be a sign i
shouldn't be at the gym you'd never
think that it goes with the territory
everyone knows this build a bicep or a
tricep or a chest or legs you have to
break it down suffer and sacrifice for
it to grow so while it's happening
there's no part of you that says this
isn't right in fact the indication of
the pain and sacrifice and sweat don't
you feel better at the gym you're like
wow i really sacrificed today i really
suffered so in that area we all know to
the extent we suffer and sacrifices to
the extent we grow
and your body is a metaphor for the rest
of your life but the rest of our life
every time we sweat every time we
sacrifice every time we suffer
we don't do what we do at the gym we
start saying well wait a minute maybe
i'm not supposed to be doing this maybe
i'm not cut out maybe it's not my
destiny maybe i just can't do it it's
the most unbelievable ridiculous
conclusion we draw but it's what
everybody does
which is another form of distraction is
doubt
the coins flip on each other all the
time don't they another form of
distraction is just doubt and doubt
comes from the suffer it comes from a
loss it comes from fear it comes from
the sacrifice and so just remember this
you're supposed to suffer and sacrifice
so let me ask you a question what are
you willing to risk in order to make
your dream come true nothing ventured
nothing gained you're gonna take a risk
maybe it's financial maybe it's a risk
of time maybe it's a risk at your job
maybe it's a risk of looking bad maybe
it's a risk of failing of falling on
your face of going broke of going
through pain of going through anxiety
maybe it's even a risk in a relationship
that's just going to be difficult while
you do this what are you willing to risk
in order to win
and you have to accept that because
remember what i'm going to tell you the
price you will pay for not making your
dream come true
is far greater than the one that you
will pay to make it come true
want me to say it again the price you
will pay the suffering you will go
through to make your dream come true is
incredibly small infinitely smaller than
the price you will pay if you never do
you'll pay that one the rest of your
life and so ask yourself what you're
willing to risk what's the price you're
willing to pay because what most people
do
when they're trying to chase their dream
or their big outcome the whole time
they're negotiating the price in their
head they're negotiating it should i
continue to do it is it worth it i don't
know if i can continue anymore it's
getting higher and that price is failure
that price is set back that price is
looking bad that price can be financial
literally a physical price and what
happens is if you don't negotiate that
price in advance it's going to steal
your focus and energy and become another
distraction one of the great
distractions of chasing our dreams is
this thing that goes off in our head as
we're negotiating the price we're paying
should i keep paying it is it getting
too high is it too much and you'll have
people in your ear it's too big a
sacrifice you're going through too much
and you begin to negotiate it in your
mind it distracts all your focus you
can't be executing and negotiating
simultaneously if you're in your head
negotiating and negotiating and
negotiating you can't execute so
negotiate it now
negotiate it with me now what are you
willing to pay for me when i'm after
something big as long as it's legal
ethical and moral i'll sacrifice
everything else but i will not sacrifice
anything legal anything unethical or
anything immoral but beyond that i'm
gonna get it and i know that negotiation
comes up front i accept the suffering i
accept the sacrifice i know the
sacrifice is far smaller than the one
i'll pay if i don't do it and i
eliminate distractions and i go freaking
get what i want in my life just like you
can and this needs to be your recipe as
well if you're one of these people who's
still negotiating whether it's worth it
maybe you've got someone in your head
making you question it that is a poverty
and scarcity mentality let me prove it
to you when i didn't have money and i
spent most of my life with none
just like you
what do we do when we go into a store we
don't go get what we want we go get what
we think we can afford and so i spent
the majority of my life flipping price
tags over i didn't buy the shirt i
wanted i buy the one that i could afford
i bought things based on price not worth
and so i'm sure you know i didn't buy
the car i wanted i bought the car i
could afford so when i was broke and i
had scarcity what do you do when you're
in that position you negotiate price you
flip price tags what's the cost what's
the cost what's the cost what's the cost
not what do you want
when i was poor everywhere i went flip
the price tag what's the cost what's the
cost what's the cost what's the cost i
was constantly negotiating the price for
everything in my life you do that when
you come from a place of scarcity of
being poor
successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction they don't
look at price they look at worth
is this worth it
if you're constantly looking at the
price tag you'll eventually relent
you'll eventually give in stop
negotiating the price it's a freeing
experience to totally commit when you
totally commit to a relationship to a
business to your fitness to your faith
it's a freeing powerful it's almost like
removing kryptonite from your life when
you totally commit can you do that the
people around you always it's costing
too much it's costing too much and
you're going maybe it's costing too much
you gotta start going no it's worth it
it's not the price it's the worth it's a
subtle distinction in your life that
same scarcity mentality we do in going
after our dreams we want to acquire our
dream you can't be in price tag mode
what's it cost what's it cost what's the
cost you never get what you want decide
in advance what it's going to cost and
then decide here's the subtle
distinction successful people don't
negotiate the cost of something they
negotiate whether it's worth it
that's subtle it's very subtle if you're
a person who's always thinking about
what it's costing you and the sacrifice
towards your dream you're always going
to be negotiating it but if you can
decide in advance that the cost is worth
it the negotiation stops and you go
execute what i'm telling you is if you
really want something bad enough it's
worth it it's worth it so start to feed
yourself the worth question over and
over and over again not the cost
question cost is a distraction worth is
a focus mechanism this is so worth it
it's so worth it it's so worth it focus
is you cost distracts you also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number four do the work with mel
robbins you need to do the work okay
you got to do the work
because it's only through your actions
that you will accomplish what you want
let's say uh that you've always wanted
to climb a particular mountain okay
there's a mountain called haystack it's
not even that tall so i should probably
pick a bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time and then all of a sudden it
starts to rain and you go i don't think
i want to do this because i don't think
i feel like doing this and next thing
you know you are back in the car driving
back down the road to that little diner
that you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain
you must stop creating excuses for why
you can't or don't feel like it and you
must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also
been putting in the time every day
consistently to not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through
the resistance the fear the obstacles
the
the excuses that are stopping you now
and feel proud in every fiber of your
being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud
that's how you use manifesting to get
what you want that's how you leverage
all the science and research to train
and prepare your mind body and spirit to
help you get what you want and that's
how you hack the motivation and
inspiration that you need to take the
actions that get you everything that you
want and deserve in life rule number
five believe with brendan burchard i'm
often asked brendan how can i believe in
myself more you know sometimes we get
knocked down sometimes we just struggle
for days or weeks or months or or
decades you know and we have that like i
just lost faith in myself somewhere i
was so confident in my in my teens or or
my 20s or my 30s or whenever and now i
lost my mojo man i just don't i don't
have the confidence in the in the vibe
and the pop and i just
i lost faith in myself what can i do
and i don't have a pat easy answer for
that but i got five ideas here that
might just help you i'm outside here at
my writer's villa in oregon and i
thought you know what why don't we just
talk about this it's a tough topic but
let's take it on so forgive the sounds
of nature if we got them forgive the
sounds of anything going by but let's
rock and roll number one way to start to
believe in yourself is
momentum
now i know off the bat if you really
hate yourself right now you're like
thanks brendan i got no momentum that's
why i hate myself so hold on
i'll get to the mindset stuff i'll get
to the emotional stuff but sometimes
believing in yourself is just tactically
winning a little bit each day
you know just a little bit of a win
can give you that dopamine that says oh
good job reward i feel better it can be
a very simple neurological payoff of
just achieving a couple small goals and
as you've heard me say anytime you're
dealing with difficulty it can be just
simple things but it's got to be
momentum so whatever you're doing in
your life if you got a job think about
what small things can i do tomorrow to
move ahead
if you're dealing with a difficulty in a
relationship what would be a simple win
a simple moment of appreciation just
something they could say or you could
say to put some more pop and energy back
into that relationship just one smile
one kiss one good date can change the
game for you also if it's just something
simple you can do in your own your own
health look sometimes going to the gym
and leaving you feel a little better you
know just a little bit of movement has
been proven to change people's states of
minds and their emotions too so just get
in the gym or get a little bit of small
goal setting get a little bit of
momentum forward in any area of your
life that's at least the beginning and
then
do it again the next day
don't just go and crush it tomorrow and
then be a jerk and do nothing and watch
seven seasons of netflix on the next day
momentum is daily little things every
single day adds up to greatness
second big piece and this is more of the
emotional side integration my friend
integration
people who don't believe in themselves
it's often it's not that there hasn't
been evidence that they shouldn't
believe in themselves they've had some
wins they've had some goals that came
true they they made the magic happen but
they never integrated the win
they never had a good thing happen and
they sat there at the end of the night
thinking about that good thing that
happened and and allowing it to come
into their heart
allowing whatever they did to to give
themselves credit for it permission to
feel good about it to say you know what
i i did this today
it went well today that worked today and
to integrate that win integrate that
success integrate that moment into their
heart into their identity as a human
being what happens is most of us we
knock off the checklist and did it did
it did it did it did it did it and five
years later after all these did it did
it did it made it happen made it happen
crush the question question question
five years later we feel the same about
ourselves the same level of confidence
the same level of belief in ourselves
because we didn't allow those things to
enter
our psyche enter our spirit as strength
we didn't we took we had momentum
externally but we didn't have any
momentum internally building our
character and our strength we never
achieved that sense of pride or
ownership of what we did
we didn't own it
that we did it so we never got stronger
that means you need an integration
practice at the end of the day just sit
down at the end of the day and go what
worked today what did i do today what
little thing should i allow myself a
little bit of credit for what did i say
that was nice or kind what did i send
away that i got done what did i finish
what goal did i move a little closer to
and just at the end of the day to allow
that to come in
this isn't about just pepping ourselves
up and saying i'm awesome i'm awesome
i'm awesome with no evidence i'm saying
you know you got some momentum integrate
that now own that you did the work today
you fought the good fight you finished
the day you're still alive you know what
you need to go do tomorrow integrate
that success give yourself that credit
you'll develop that strength of spirit
that's so important
if you don't believe in yourself after
all that hey bub
get some feedback
you know most people fear this when you
don't believe in yourself you don't want
any feedback because they might say
you're stupid or you suck or you're ugly
and you know if they do that you're
getting feedback from the wrong people
sometimes it's necessary to get feedback
from the people that we love feedback
from people we know like and trust and
just say hey can i ask you a question
what am i doing that you're seeing that
seems right because right now i don't
feel like i'm doing anything right and
they'll say what are you talking about
no you're smart you're good you've been
doing this sometimes people can give us
feedback and help us see that we are
doing better than we think
because maybe you're perfectionist or
maybe you grew up with somebody who
pushed so hard on you you never
integrated any successes and sometimes
you need somebody pushing hard at you
saying good job kid
you're doing all right
i'm proud of you i see that you're
working hard here i see that you're
trying so sometimes it's about getting
around a new social circle of people who
are strivers who are also struggling who
are fighting hard who can give you that
feedback and say good job keep at it and
if you do get negative feedback over and
over and over assess is it real
do you need to change and shift and get
better and if you do don't hate that
don't get mad at that take that as a
challenge instead of taking things as a
insult and crying over people's comments
go huh you know what that's kind of got
some basis in reality i'm gonna take
that as a challenge i'm gonna develop
myself not to prove them wrong
but to get better allow yourself that
allow that feeling to come from the
feedback next up i love this one it's so
simple it's just priming the emotions
that we want to experience in our life
what does that mean it means doing
something in advance so we can feel it
and here's what i mean by that in the
morning every single day see i want to
be i want to be motivated and driven i
want to feel grateful for life i want to
have a sense of passion about the day
but you know what some days i wake up
and i feel like crap
so what am i going to do go through the
day and just allow my impulsive feelings
to tell me to feel like crap all day and
lose multiple days no i'm gonna say okay
i recognize i feel like crap why i
didn't sleep well or why i got this bad
attitude right now i'm gonna change it
in the morning
i do an affirmation practice and
visualization practice where what i do
is i pick up something every single
morning i do this i grab a little just
couple paragraphs maybe i read from my
bible maybe i read from one of my books
or another book it's a passage i have a
bunch of passages in my notes section my
phone too if i'm on the road and i'll
just
read it out loud pretending that i'm
like in my most passionate happy place
in my life so i'll be
reading out loud some franklin delano
roosevelt i'll be reading out loud to
martin luther king i'll be reading out
loud some napoleon hill or reading out
loud some earl nightingale as loud as i
can and that
voice activates a power which activates
an emotion which activates my day
so you just got a prime emotion or
sometimes i'll be in the shower and i'll
say what can i do today
or what i'm going to do today that would
bring a laugh
what can i do today that i'm excited for
and i'll just get my energy up like
don't wait to have good energy in life
remember as i always say the power plant
doesn't have energy it generates it you
don't have happiness you generate it so
choose to prime the emotions you want to
experience in life cultivate it summon
your energy versus hoping a good one
lands on you and you'll start to feel
better about yourself and about life and
the last big one you knew i was going to
go there
love you know
you already know the thing about love
yourself and maybe in some ways you've
never allowed that
you've never noticed the beautiful
things you've done in your life
so you've never allowed yourself to love
yourself
but at some point
you've got to recognize that there's a
love that's beyond you
and beyond me and beyond your actions
and that love is whatever brought us
here alive today some would say it's
god's will and god's love some people
it's the randomness of the universe some
people it's nature some people it's
whatever
but there is something way beyond us
and there's a way to access that and a
way to honor that and the way to honor
that is to recognize that you are unique
about of seven billion people no one is
like you specifically
and
at least take that as a moment saying
okay
i'm meant to live my uniqueness
i'm out i'm supposed to love the things
that make me odd and weird i'm supposed
to love the things that make me strong
i'm supposed to i was made this way so
let me honor what's good about that and
what's not good about that let me work
on that let me set a schedule to get
better at that so that i can not only
honor what i've been given but i can
give something back to by getting better
and that aspect of doing that that
brings in so much joy and so much
strength in our life is love loving
ourselves loving the process and of
course the greatest way to believe in
ourselves is to love other people that
they become so grateful for us
that they give us some of that feedback
that they that there's so much
appreciation and love and joy in the
moment with others that you can't help
but just feel that vibe that there's an
emotional contagion when other people
around you are feeling loved and cared
for and excited about life it's hard not
to rub off on you a little bit and you
start to say you know what life isn't so
bad and you know what i deserve to feel
good here right now too and you know
what you start getting some momentum
some wins you integrate those wins you
get some feedback to get better and all
of a sudden you start to believe in
yourself again all of a sudden you start
to live
the charge
rule number six take responsibility for
yourself with dean graziosi hey it's
dean graziosi and i think it's time we
get real
um
i just hear so many conversations right
now about politics and whose fault is it
the last president the future president
no matter where you live in the world is
it the in here is in the states is it
the republicans or the democrats the
liberals are the conservatives
is it because my mom and dad didn't give
me the foundation for success is it
because the economy shifted is it
because technology has taken over the
world
man we come up with so many ways to make
it someone else's fault
no one is going to make it easy for you
no one owes you crap if you want another
level in life
the best thing the best thing you could
do is put all the responsibility on
yourself it's the most liberating thing
in the entire world when you're not
expecting anything and maybe even expect
that people around you will let you down
that it won't work out because listen
in life
in life there are two types of people
and i think you realize that
those that complain those that blame
those that are expecting something those
that want to hand out
and those that quietly
just take the lumps
those that quietly have to learn through
their own experience those that are
called dreamers
and wishers and
sometimes
capitalists and entrepreneurs which in
today's world has kind of got a bad
stigma isn't that terrible the thing
that made the country i live in america
the greatest country in the world
innovative people who are going after
their dreams with no restrictions not
held back put their everything to
on the line risk all they have to create
uh to create momentum to create success
to create jobs for people to fuel the
economy sometimes they're the bad people
in today's world while there's a group
of people waiting for a handout from
those that are willing to take the
chance listen i'm just going to say it
like it is
if you went to if you went to college
and you worked your tail off you didn't
go out drinking you didn't go out
partying
you didn't stay up all night
you weren't taking
you know adderall day in the day to go
to stay awake and something else at
night and then party until four o'clock
in the morning and
you put the focus in you put the energy
in and you got straight a's
good for you congratulations you took
ownership maybe you're even paying your
own college debt
congratulations for
taking responsibility knowing it's on
you that you want a bigger better future
and you're going after it but what if
you did all that you made those
sacrifices you're paying the bill and
someone else comes in
someone else
someone paid and i'm not saying it's bad
i do it for my own kids but you paid all
their college tuition was paid
and they went to every single party and
they partied all night and they took
stuff to stay up and took stuff to go to
bed and and i'm not judging in any way
this is just a story
they did all that
and because they weren't at class
because they didn't work hard because
they didn't study because they didn't
make the sacrifices you did
they were failing
they were failing
and then
at the end of the semester
your professor came and said i know you
guys that have been working hard and got
straight a's
i know you've been working hard
but you know this other group
with d's and f's
they're really nice and i know they
didn't do the work and i know they
partied
what let's do this let's give everyone a
c plus
just so we can make it even let's give
the participation trophy to everyone
because they're here how the heck would
you feel
you would be so pissed that you put in
the work you did the effort you put in
the effort and all of a sudden you're
getting
penalized you're getting penalized i
should say because you did the work and
someone else didn't
think about this
isn't it how it is sometimes in life and
in business
you go after your dreams no one knows
that you had to go against your family
and friends calling you crazy that you
had to raise the money or put money on
credit cards or you had to stay up all
night week after week trying to figure
this out you had to work on your own
personal development because you wanted
to keep things moving forward when you
were scared to death when uncertainty
was at an all-time high when you felt
impostor syndrome about an inch away or
a millimeter away from robbing your
dreams you kept going forward you failed
more than once you hired the wrong
person you kept moving forward finally
you get momentum
finally you start getting energies
finally you start hiring people finally
you start hiring new people and doing
new things and you start fueling the
economy fueling your own life and then
you hire more people and have more
success and things keep going harder
faster stronger
and then you get to a certain point and
what do people say
wow she's so lucky
and why is she having that new car and
why did they move into that new
neighborhood and i can't believe that
they joined that country club
let's penalize them they're wealthy
they're rich
it's like the modern day tax the rich
because they don't pay enough right it's
like let's penalize them for the success
they've done like it magically came out
of thin air
listen
let's stop being envious and start
getting our own
because if someone else can do it so can
you
listen now when i say this i don't want
you to think i use that silly college
analogy
there's some people who struggle
there's some people that
work their tail off to try to get good
grades and it doesn't work i watch that
with my daughter sometimes right my son
it's easy straight a student my daughter
works really hard
to get the grades that she has it's it's
a little more difficult for her
those people should be glorified because
they're in the hunt they're working hard
they're trying to figure it out
but they're not blaming someone else
they're not saying i'm not that smart so
someone needs to fix this someone needs
to wave a magic wand we should all get c
pluses for doing nothing that's just not
the way the world works if you like that
there's a lot of countries around the
world that pretty much allow you to be
equal how does that work out how have
they been throughout the history of time
go spend six months there and see if you
like it or
we could say listen i'm in control of my
own destiny i have the opportunity to do
what i want to do in life
but you are going to be judged by the
things that you do if you're envious
envious of someone else making money but
you're binging out on netflix
and you're spending hours and hours on
social media and you're sitting around
with your friends drinking coffee or
having a cocktail complaining about all
these other people really are you doing
what it takes
it's one of the rare times now i'm
recording this while i'm taking a walk
so we heard someone with a little
mexican muse or spanish music which was
awesome we heard cars going by but i had
a message i want to share with you share
with you today so i just clicked my
phone on and hit record so whether
you're watching this or listening to
this audio maybe some of that's
distracting but i hope you're listening
to this message
there is no one coming to save us there
is no one to blame
there is no easy button if you look at
the most successful actors comedians
business owners people in a great family
with a great body
people that have great personal
development people that are good parents
and have incredible kids none of it came
easy they had to put the work no one hit
a button and made it easy for them they
had to do it and if you look at the
people that it came too easy do you know
this is not this is not in any way
disrespect but do you know many trust
fund kids if you know any of them that
are balanced and happy and excited about
what they've accomplished
i don't
but i surely know a lot of people that
struggled and fought and were told no
and criticized and
and lost everything and had no respect
from their family and friends because
they thought they were a dreamer and
thought they were crazy i know a lot of
them that have made
the money they always dreamed of have
have donated more money than anyone
could imagine are happy as heck because
they went after it and realized they
were in control
so maybe this is just a little
rant today maybe it's just the mood i'm
in to say
don't expect anything from anybody
expect that
your government will let you down expect
your friends might let you down expect
it don't judge them
and realize this is on me
if i want more let me learn what other
people have done to get more
if i want more i might have to change my
mindset i might have to read those books
study the past
model someone who's already been
successful
if i want more out of my life
i gotta stop waiting with my hand out
and time to get up at five a.m and
figure out how to
gain the capabilities needed to live the
life you want
and if you're happy with where your life
is and you don't want more well then
you're probably still not listening to
this you probably got mad at me earlier
and if you are someone that wants more
then let's just do it
you know seems easy for me to say right
i i get to live in the house of my
dreams it's my home behind me i feel
blessed to have that
but i lived in a trailer park as a kid
i lived with my dad in a bathroom for
almost a year of our lives where we
couldn't afford anything else
i got made fun of for having dyslexia
i barely got out of high school
but i had a dream and a goal and i
realized no one was coming to save me i
had a mom who worked three jobs to make
90 bucks a week and had nothing and no
quality of life and i couldn't wait to
retire her and by 27 i was sending my
mom a check every week i've been sending
her a check every week
for 20 plus years i bought my mom a
house i bought my dad a house i bought
my parents their cars
i get to
give my life my children a life that i
could have never imagined with security
and strength that they could carry on a
legacy i don't say that to brag
i say that because that's what's
possible
when you decide it's possible
remember stop waiting for someone to fix
it stop getting sucked into the news
doesn't matter what your politics are
get sucked into you get sucked into
unleashing that full potential that god
or the universe whatever you believe in
gave you when you unleash that you
realize
you don't need anybody and there's no
limits to what you can achieve
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is listen to
your voice with jay shannon i start off
the chapter with this beautiful thought
from charles horton cooley and i love
telling it because it's just it's just
the best and i think it was written in
like the 1900s and he said today the
challenge is i'm not what i think i am
i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am it's
crazy ben and it's like it blows my mind
every time i say it gives me the chills
like i feel it and the reason why i
start with identity is because i think
that's the root of all our challenges
and the first step to thinking like a
monk is starting at the root not
starting at the symptoms or the
superficial or the surface level but
let's go to the root
if you're playing a role if you're
wearing a mask
if you're
dressed in clothes that are not yours
then you end up living a life that's not
yours and in the book i give this
example of method acting yes
yeah amazing i'm a massive movie junkie
and i love method actors so people like
heath ledger of course from the dark
knight series you've got jared leto so
jared leto when he played the joker in
this is not in the book in suicide squad
he used to send dead rats in the mail to
his co-stars he did because he was
trying to get into the mindset of how
someone that perverted would behave
and then daniel dave lewis when he was
filming for gangs of new york he's
actually wearing these coats that are
centuries old so that he can get into
character when he's off camera yeah when
he can feel it right he's not wearing
watches he's not carrying around his
mobile phone they're speaking in the
accents and he talks about how he
actually went crazy because guess what
when you fake being someone for so long
you think it's your reality
and that's what happens to all of us we
play a role at work we play a role at
home we play a role with our family we
play a role with our friends and then we
think that role is us
and we lose ourselves and to me that is
the core reason why we're chasing things
that are not important to us
we're unhappy despite reaching accolades
and we feel dissatisfied so what should
our identity be then
our identity should start with
unlearning
everything that we think we know about
ourselves
how do we unlearn so the best method of
unlearning is this first and i'm going
to get really strategic and tactical
because i think that people need to know
what to do rather than a concept the
first thing you do is write down
everything you currently are chasing in
your life make a lot of goals your
dreams your goals your dreams published
anything that you're currently chasing
and pursuing okay write them down you
can write down three you can random five
you can write down 10 depending on how
ambitious you are second line ask
yourself what is the source of that
where did you get that idea did you get
that idea from
a tv show you saw did you get that idea
from your parents did you get that idea
from your mom and your dad your sister
your cousin did you get that idea
because your friend just got proposed to
on instagram did you get that idea
because your friend just got promoted
did you get that idea because
you just broke up right or did you get
an idea because you just feel it when
you do it then you feel alive
give me a specific example that you had
when you were 15 18 was like a goal or
accomplishment that you were chasing and
where it came from absolutely so my my
goal when i was young was to be an
investment banker
and when i really asked myself where did
that come from it came because in my
community small community in london the
most successful person financially was
an investment banker so i believed you
had to be an investment banker to be
successful right so when i ask myself
that question where does that come from
it comes from society's version of
success not mine and then the third
thing you ask yourself is well then what
is mine what is coming from inside of me
and if you just do that three-step
process now what you're doing is you're
filtering out the noise and you're
starting to listen to your voice the
thing is you've got a voice inside of
you but it's quiet it's like it's like
jay like take note of me like lewis like
you know and it's just like trying to
get through and the noise of everyone
else's opinions is so loud so this way
you filter it how do we start to find
out what we truly want then not based on
what other people think is success how
do we how do we listen to ourselves and
if you've been chasing something your
whole life how do you say well actually
that's not what i want
this is yeah one of the biggest mistakes
we make is that we confuse
inexperience
with being unqualified
so because we've not tried a lot of
things we just naturally believe that we
can't be that good at them so if i've
never spoken on a stage i just think oh
i'm probably not good at that or if i've
never played golf i'd probably think i'm
probably not good at that and so we
start writing off things without even
trying them so the best method i can
share with someone is take the next
month
take the next four weekends in the month
that gives you eight days
and get really tactical every single day
that's why you're playing tennis a lot
right now yeah
take the eight days go join a course an
online course or workshop go and shadow
a friend go to a seminar a conference go
to reading a book listen to podcasts go
and expose yourself to eight different
things in a month eight different things
eight different things in a month
and guess what in a month you will have
learned what you probably would have
learned in eight years because most of
us test one new thing a year maybe maybe
if that exactly right like some people
don't even do that but if you do eight
different things in a month and this is
how you have to see it if you went to
eight different restaurants in a month
you ask yourself after you eat a meal
like i had that burrito or i had that
taco did i like it
right the first question you asked
yourself is did i gotta try it first you
gotta try it first you gotta go to the
restaurant yeah there's no point so
you're gonna say did i like it
the second question you ask yourself is
why did i or why did i not like it
like why is so important i think too
many people just go i like it or i don't
like it why didn't i like and the third
question you have to ask yourself really
really simple is do i want to do it
again
and if you do
that's where you start uncovering is so
my point is inexperience do not
misinterpret inexperience for a lack of
qualification i'm guessing you're doing
things in your life right now that you
would have ridden off if you didn't try
i know you've talked about writing a
bestselling book you've talked about it
with this amazing documentary this is a
documentary i mean i never believed i
could do half the things i'm doing today
and you know that because we met when i
was just creating content on social
media
and it's like now when you see things
expand you're like you don't know until
you give it a go and ask yourself do i
enjoy it yes
so i grew up very competitive
and you talk about competition as one of
these i can't remember if it's like four
or five different things competition is
one of the things that's actually like
um
i wish i had the page yeah here but you
talk about competition as like not the
highest level of ourself yes
in my entire life
i was competitive was driven to beat
other people
and in the last seven years i've shifted
so much i'm still competitive still win
but i'm not like
hurt if i lose
i'm not upset i'm not it doesn't defeat
me emotionally whereas before it used to
be like this was my identity
winning i had to win
now it's like okay what did i learn what
did i gain from the experience did i
have fun did i enjoy it did i inspire
people even if i didn't win in this
situation
in in chapter two you talk about
negativity and the quote you use is
is it it is impossible to build one's
own happiness on the unhappiness of
others
does competition and unhappiness link
together in your mind like if we need to
be
competitive to be happy in order someone
else loses
how do we how do we manage ourselves in
this competitive world of
winning in sports of building a bigger
business some of these different things
being number one in new york times best
sell this
how do we manage that
with this world brand but also wanting
to be happy at the same time yeah what a
great question so
the way i see it is that competition
in and of itself
is not good or bad and and this is like
the monk mindset on 99 of things that
this mug is not good or bad it can be
filled with water or it could be filled
with poison yes and so competition i'll
give you an example as monks our
competition is in how much love and
respect we showed to each other that's
your confidence that's what you compete
on or how long can we meditate no no no
i can better take longer than you so if
any monk is hit and i did this plenty of
times really if i sat there and i
thought oh yeah look at him he's
scratching his back he got out like he
moved your meditation just got destroyed
all the value and so monks will never
ask how long you meditate they focus on
how deep you meditate and someone who
meditates deep doesn't go on about how
deep it was but but you compete for
showing respect you compete for serving
each other you compete for how well you
can collaborate and i feel like you live
this yes like i i i feel like you
haven't seen you used to do that yeah
but you did it now like you think like a
monk like i feel like we're always
trying to find a way where we can be
better friends to each other and support
each other and so you're competing on
that and and that's a positive
competition that i think you can have so
you can still use and this is the
beautiful thing about the monk mindset
you can use any
thing in a positive way now in your
second question about what does it mean
about business and new york times about
seller lists and being number one
this is how i see it
if while you're writing your book if
while you're recording your podcast if
you're sitting there going i hope this
is going to be number one this better be
number one i hope i sell more i hope i
sold more copies than this person who's
launching at the same time because
that's the only way well guess what
now the quality of your output right now
has just dropped
because guess what you're now living 75
in the future and you're 25 right now
and guess what this 25 is gonna define
that future goal and result and your
happiness and your happiness whether you
get the result totally whereas for me
when i was writing my book and of course
i want my book to be a bestselling book
of course i want my podcast to do well
of course we don't do anything for it to
be lost like no one does that but what i
do know is that when i'm creating when
i'm producing when i'm writing
that's all i'm doing see the truth is
that only two percent of the world's
population can multitask now the crazy
thing is where are those two presents
when people hear that they think i'm in
that oh i'm in that two percent like
everyone thinks that they're in there
but most of us are 98
yeah and the truth is there is no such
thing as multitasking what it is is fast
switching between two tasks so the
quality is just dropping because you can
actually you cannot do two things at one
time you cannot no one genuinely can do
two things at once i guess you could
maybe like pat your head and do this the
same yeah
you can't do something productive at the
same time right or creative and so what
i'm saying is that when you're sitting
here going this needs to be number one
you are reducing that things ability to
be number one because it now doesn't
have your full focus right
so so that's the difference maker that
you can want to be number one there's
nothing wrong with that but you can't
keep comparing what number one is to
someone else's goal too because
everyone's got a different trajectory
like there are some people that are kind
of come in and do really well at one
thing and you're going to do really well
at another and that's why competition
has to first be in your space like don't
compete in a space that's not yours
right because now you're just trying to
be someone else again and you get lost
your identity exactly
the biggest difference between you
and the people who you look up to
are that they started
and you're still thinking about it
it's one of the most frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs
that i deal with on a day-to-day basis
is that seeing so much potential in
people seeing so much heart and love and
cares like you you could be serving so
much and helping so much and having such
a big impact
and and
we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too i was stuck it took
me forever to get started and
i thought i had to have the the perfect
cameraman my first video if you go back
and watch my channel i had my friend
come and film it and record it for me
because i was worried about it not being
perfect enough that i didn't know the
gear and didn't know the microphone and
the lighting and the setup and i i
memorized the script because i didn't
want to say the wrong words i had to be
perfect uh
most of my early videos were still
mostly voice over
because i could write a script and have
it perfect and just have b-roll and it
wouldn't be me on camera afraid of
making mistakes and saying the wrong
things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow
you know if you look at my journey of
making
what for five years seven thousand
subscribers something like that
it was i was stuck i was i was
i was too afraid to do the next thing i
was too afraid to get in the race i was
making content at least that was one
decent thing for whatever reason i stay
consistent on on doing stuff but i was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and
a lot of you
are already way better than than i was
when i started
and when i'm on interviews and i'm i'm
doing uh events and presentations and i
see the audience and i see who's there
and i see the skill and the and the
heart just the this is the thing that
kills me the most it's like the hearts
like you want you've got such a good
heart you want to do so much
and then
there's just no action there's no
momentum because of the fear
if you could make one change
this year
that would really move the needle
it would be to stop judging yourself for
the content that you're making or the
product you're putting out or the
service and just expect it to suck and
keep going
so when people ask me
should i should i do this business or
this business should i do that business
or this one's like well i don't know you
know like at the end of the day it's
gonna be what you love doing all of them
could work
every business model can work and has
worked it's what's gonna be the right
one for you and you won't know until
you get out there and start doing it
right it's like how do you know what
your favorite food is until you get out
there and do it how do you know if you
like
coffee or not you know
you have to go off and you take a sip
and then you find out you can't think
your way through this so you can't think
your way you can have some planning but
your planning won't save you at the end
of the day you have to go off and just
do something about it and in the doing
you'll figure out
what makes you come alive and keep going
so let's make it practical like let's
give you some steps for how to actually
get in the race and start taking some
action
step one
understand
or at least tell yourself that great
ideas flow through you great ideas flow
through you that because you came up
with the idea that it's a good idea stop
judging and stop telling yourself you
suck stop telling yourself someone like
you can't do it that great ideas flow
through you this is a good idea you need
to go do something about it right even
just
telling yourself that shortcuts the fear
because all of the reasons in your head
for why you can't do it is really just
fear if you think about making content
and you're worried about the microphone
and the camera and the
gear and all that that's just fear
talking it's just you're afraid that it
won't be good and so you're trying to
cover your bases and we come up with all
these logical reasons why we can't do it
but really just fear talking so
cut through the fear by telling yourself
that
great ideas flow through you
that you don't want to be sitting here
three years later
still stuck in the same spot
right what's the difference well how
much action you took over those three
years and most of us
are are stuck in inaction
because we're paralyzed by fear and
we've come up with rational reasons why
we can't do the thing so one great ideas
flow through you trust them and do
something about them two apply what i
call the two percent difference and so
most of the time what's the first thing
we do when we come with an idea
when you come up with an id you think
it's a great idea you're going to start
a channel you're going to write a book
you're going to create this product
service company whatever you come up
with a great idea
the first thing we do is usually
planning right plan plan plan i need to
plan here's what my perfect world looks
like i'm going to plan all the way out
and what ends up happening is you spend
your best energy planning the first step
in my opinion should not be planning the
first step should be some kind of
imperfect action because what ends up
happening is you get all this energy and
motivation and you feel like you're
unstoppable and you can do it this is
such a good idea
and then you start spending your time
planning and researching when does that
happen is you wake up the next day and
the next day and
your energy and your belief starts to
drop it's like oh what was i thinking i
can't do that who am i to do that the
the doubts and insecurities and the
fears all start to pop in and so you you
stop
and nothing ends up happening besides a
list of ideas and you're planning and
research but that doesn't that doesn't
get you paid that doesn't get the
service out there doesn't actually help
anybody and so
planning is important it just shouldn't
be the first step the first step should
be some kind of imperfect action just
start doing something anything you you
want to make a youtube channel great
pull out your phone and make a video
what do you see on the video it doesn't
matter just speak from the heart like
hey
i want to start a youtube channel i've
been thinking about doing this for a
bunch of years and i've always been too
afraid and
now i've decided that i'm going to go
off and do it and i don't know what i'm
going to talk about i'm going to do my
best
and hopefully you'll support me all
right see you soon
post there's your video was it great no
but it's everything because you you
started doing something you think about
a a fitness plan that people are going
on
what do people normally do on a fitness
plan well you you're researching all do
i do crossfit do i do weights do i do
cardio do i do zumba do i do salsa
dancing and you're so caught up we all
get this we all get so caught up in what
the perfect plan is that we never
actually do anything where the the best
thing you can do is go and do ten
push-ups right now
or five or two however many you can do
are those two push-ups going to make any
difference
for the long-term health no i mean no
you're not building muscle from two
push-ups obviously but
the mo the act of momentum is the thing
that matters because in doing the two
push-ups maybe tomorrow you do four the
next day you do six next thing you do
eight and you're starting to build the
habit of somebody who does push-ups that
then can lead you to do more research to
find out oh i was doing the push-ups all
wrong here's a better way to do it or i
should be doing this instead you'll
learn as you go and the research in the
plan is important it just can't be the
first step
so step one again is expect that great
ideas flow through you that that idea
that came to you is good is worthy you
should do it you should at least try it
step number two is two percent
difference what that means is
don't plan to get the hundred percent
for focus on the first two percent most
of us will plan to figure out what the
100 looks like you won't know what's the
first two percent you can take action on
right now and just go do it and then
step three is just expect to suck at the
beginning
we expect we don't expect to be great at
the start but we expect to be good we
expect to be at least average at the
start of whatever we do we never think
it's going to be easy i mean some people
do i guess but for the most part you
don't think whatever you're getting into
is going to be easy but you don't expect
it to be as hard as it is and you don't
expect to be as bad as you are at the
thing and it doesn't mean that you're
bad as a human it just means that you're
bad at the skill
and so how do you get skills well by by
practicing by doing it by training right
and so you're going to be way worse
than you thought you would be at the
beginning that's okay you just don't
have the skill yet so i go into any new
thing expecting to suck just completely
expect to suck expect it to be a total
failure
and if it's not then great
and every day you get up and you do it
again you'll be a little bit better and
you'll suck a little bit less because
you're developing the skills you can get
really really good at something if you
have passion energy and you're pouring
time into actually improving at it where
most people
will just make one thing
see how much it sucks and then never go
back to it so just expect it to be
terrible at the beginning
don't worry so much about how much of a
failure that first one was and then you
keep going keep you make another one
tomorrow and another one tomorrow
another tomorrow and you will get better
if you follow that process this is this
is how you actually start becoming the
person who you want to be you start
getting the results and the impact that
you want to have
you've got the heart and the talent and
the the abilities
and the care
the difference is just there's no
momentum or there's not enough momentum
for what you're capable of and so if you
follow those three steps
right great ideas flow through you
believe it follow the two percent
difference instead of planning research
and do something you need action and
then three expect to suck and keep going
you get that momentum you need start
changing your life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the seven steps for massive
success check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and we'll see you then you have
to be all in and it's the hardest thing
to do because if it fails then you can
feel like a failure i think of this idea
of performance necessity two stories
kind of come to mind one is i was
working with an olympic gold medalist
sprinter